[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's albert breer the senior nfl
reporter
lead content strategist for the monday
morning quarterback
and uh explain to me if this is big news
that aaron rodgers is not
at the mandatory camp starting today
albert no i mean i think the
the real inflection point for all this
is really always going to be the start
of training camp and that
um relates back to the fact that he
hasn't been at the off-season program
in general you know and so his
willingness to walk away from a half
million dollar
um workout bonus i think tells you if
the packers were going to find him 93
dollars which they can for missing the
three-day mini camp
um this week then he'd be willing to do
that too um you know really i think you
know all along where the rubbers met the
road here
has been the beginning of training camp
and i think the packers know it
the packers were aware that he wasn't
going to show up today
and you know now going forward they have
five six weeks to come to some sort of
resolution
upside here i guess is that you get to
see jordan love for another couple days
um you know next week matt laflores
actually made the
uh the last part of the offseason
program um for guys who have workout
bonuses
you know optional where they can you
know attend things virtually
so really the next big thing um coming
down the road
to coming down the road for rogers as
the start of training camp i'm still
trying to understand the timing of all
of this let's say aaron rodgers doesn't
want to stay in green bay
then at some point he has to be
concerned about where am i going
and when am i getting there and what is
that team going to have to get
give up to get me there and have i
really improved
my you know position here or if he's
staying in green bay
what has to happen other than firing the
gm that he's willing to go back i i
just keep waiting for some kind of
information here that moves us
in one direction or another yeah and i i
honestly
like like i think we talked about last
week um
you know like julio would have been an
olive branch to me um you know i don't
know how you
fix the fact that you haven't been as
aggressive as he'd like
with free agency and the draft gone and
now with the trade opportunity like
julio presented
off the table as well um so you know i
i think you almost have to make some
sort of promise that
you know aaron we're going to pay you
now and
we are going to either a change the way
we do
business or b trade you to wherever you
want to be traded to after this season i
mean that's really it
and you know i think what you're talking
about the way you laid that out dan
is sort of like where russell wilson was
and
where um you know i think he kind of
came to the realization that the best
situation the only situation really
for him in 2021 was going to be seattle
and that doesn't mean that russell
wilson's not going to be back in the
same spot in january 22 that he wasn't
january 21. i think there's a good
likelihood he is
but he just sort of came to the
realization they're not trading me
so i might as well go in and and try to
put myself in position have the best
season i can right now
aaron rodgers isn't that point yet um
we'll see if he gets there over the next
few weeks i mean i
i guess you can't totally rule out
retirement but that that'd be a pretty
crazy option for a guy who's still at
the top of his game and
obviously the reigning mvp of the league
is we haven't even heard trade rumors
right i know well i can tell you the
other teams are monitoring like
the broncos are monitoring what's going
on here you know and they've kept an eye
on it
um you know i know other teams have kind
of you know asked around like what's
going on with aaron rodgers
the interesting thing about it you know
dan is a a lot of times like these sorts
of situations
like julio for example i i feel like
other teams had a lot of information
over the last five or six weeks on where
the julio thing was right like so
yeah the titans got him but you know the
niners and the rams and the cardinals
and the patriots and the raiders
they all knew what was going on right
like so they were at least
informed to a certain level of where
things were at
i think with the rogers situation is
completely different like where
other teams are keeping an eye on it but
they're really just as in the dark as
the packers are
on on where this is gonna go over the
next five or six weeks and
um so that makes it a little bit of a
unique situation you know
and um you know at some point obviously
everybody's gonna have to decide how
they how they move forward and that's
why i think training camp's an important
day because
they can that the packers can excuse his
absence this week and not find them and
i would think they would do that if they
want to
have any shot of repairing the
relationship you know i
i just feel like that would be like
almost a declaration of war
to to not excuse them and to find them
this week they can't do that when they
get to trading camp under the new cba
they
are required to find them fifty 000 a
day and they can't forgive those fines
after they're assessed so
that to me is really kind of the point
where some sort of decision is going to
have to come
i need shannon sharp to call aaron
rodgers and not let him know he's on the
air
and then just say hey what's up dude you
know
you want out of there he's hanging out
man what's going on
how did they confirm that story that
you you said that julio jones did not
know he was on the air with
with shannon sharp i've talked to some
people i've talked to people on all ends
of this
and i you know i like
like over the last few weeks i've sort
of been able to nail that down now it
happened to be my column on monday
but um you know through a number of
different people
um i you know i've been able to sort of
nail down the fact that julio didn't
know what was going on there
and i don't think julio it's of his
nature to
make a big deal out of it because he
doesn't make a big deal out of anything
but i think anybody who is watching that
in the moment
if you saw the way that julio
spoke and kind of the tone and
then you add that to julio's ultra
private nature like he would never
do something like like he's got we had a
10 year track record with the guy dan
yeah
has he ever done anything like that
remotely no i mean how many like do you
even know what his voice sounds like
we've had him on once seven years ago i
had him on once
i mean like that's the thing like i
think most football fans like if julio
talked into a microphone wouldn't know
it was him
you know so he's so private and that's
the thing so
um you know not only was i able to
confirm it but it's also way out of his
nature
that like he would come and just fire
this cannon
like memorial over memorial day week you
know and like i
i want out of there that's not julio's
nature to begin with so
did fox hear from the nfl huh did fox
hear from the nfl
i don't think the i know the falcons
weren't happy about it i like the fact
now i don't know about the league office
itself but i know the falcons really
weren't happy with about it and one of
the reasons why
was because they had worked really hard
to keep the trade request under wraps
and they've always like even as the
relationships been up and down over the
years
the falcons have always really respected
julio's nature
and his desire to keep things private
and the first trade request went in
two years ago you know and when that
that contract negotiation got rocky in
2019
we said you know if you don't if we
can't get a contract done
like i'm totally cool with being traded
and that never got out
right and then you know i think it was
obvious to everybody in the building
um you know when they got there in
january and february all the new guys
like
all right like i don't know if he's
going to be around this year i don't
know if he's going to want to be here
and when it was confirmed by julio
actually through his agent putting in
the trade request
like that the head coach arthur smith
came to an agreement with julio we're
going to keep this quiet and so they
worked really hard to keep that thing
quiet
for almost three months and the way it
became public
i think it really angered the falcons
i'll put it that way and so
i'm sure the falcons talk with the
league office i don't know if the league
office
lodged a complaint with fox or anything
like that but i know the falcons weren't
happy
let me go back to aaron rodgers before i
let you go and and in particular mark
murphy their ceo
when he came out and said what he said
that you know aaron is really
you know he's dividing our fan base that
felt like that was strategic in what he
was saying
and i don't know if he's saying to aaron
look you're hurting your image here you
talked about the fan base you talked
about the legacy you talked about
tradition
all these great players don't jeopardize
that and and maybe i'm reading yeah more
into it but
i was just surprised that he would say
that out loud
i don't think i mean dan how often do we
see things like that on a team website
too no like that was the other part of
it it wasn't an interview it wasn't like
he was sitting there with you and just
kind of let it go
it was on a team website like and and
and not like on camera it was
i mean like edited you know like so yeah
they had an opportunity to edit that and
everything else and so
you know i took it i just took it two
ways i think you know
more often than not in situations like
this the reality is fans
side with the laundry right like and the
reality is that most times fans aren't
gonna
side with the athlete and so i think one
way you could take it is you could say
mark murphy is acknowledging
that this isn't popular right and that
the way that they're handling this
some people are gonna side with aaron
rodgers so i think there's an
acknowledgement from the team
there that we understand that people are
going to be
some people are going to be behind aaron
rodgers on this thing
and so that was one piece of it that i
thought was not notable
and yeah i think the other piece of it's
exactly what you're talking about which
is
we really don't want to make this ugly
like and i can tell you from my own
experience having covered this the last
two or three months
um and i'll give you a little background
on this like
you know you have people you talk to
regularly in the league and everything
else
when things blew up during draft week
the way they did
and covering that in the aftermath the
packers asked to go on the record on
that
the packers wanted to go on the record
on that and brian couticus wanted to go
on the record on that and i think
part of it is they want to they were so
concerned about
the relationship you know with aaron
like that they went out of their way to
make sure anything we say
is going to be public like we don't want
to be hiding behind it we don't want to
be sourcing it
like we want like what we want us we
want to have a unified front on this and
we want to say what we're going to say
publicly
and so this to me will be the other side
of that which is exactly what you what
you're saying which is
like let's not make this ugly one way or
another let's just work together
let's not make this ugly and whatever
resolution
we come to if that means you're out of
here in a year
fine but let's do it in a better way
than maybe
the packers handled the the brett favre
thing what was it 14 years ago now
the most interesting quarterback
situation is where
i think chicago um now new england's
interesting
um san francisco's interesting but i
think in both of those places
um if those teams are contending
um and and you know obviously both those
teams have been in the super bowl
relatively recently i think there's a
good chance the rookies sit
i think the difference in chicago and
the bears have been good the last few
years is the people's jobs are on the
line
and i can tell you like to this point
andy dalton has taken
all the first team reps justin fields
has taken all the second team reps
um to this point justin fields has
blended in and what i was told is he's
playing the rookie role in that building
really really well like like has like a
little leader by example trait to him
but isn't trying to assert himself or
anything like that he knows his place
which is a good sign for his
self-awareness
and all of that i'm also told that
they're planning on continuing with this
into camp
and justin fields is going to be the
second team quarterback in camp and work
with the twos and andy dalton's going to
work with the ones that makes it tough
for fields to win the job
but fields is going to play a lot in the
preseason but their plan is to give a
ton of snaps
but albert i'm looking at the situation
in chicago and if i'm trying to hold on
to my job don't i go to the rookie
to say that's the thing like we're a
package deal
this is our future right and and so like
that's the thing is like you know you
hear about like well
is that like can this be kansas city and
matt and aggie the coach there was in
kansas city for the mahomes redshirt
year so
he's got credibility when he's talking
about it that way
i just think this is different in that
andy reid at that point was in his fifth
year and alex smith was so established
in kansas city
and patrick mahomes was more of a
curiosity than anything else at that
point like we didn't know
patrick mahomes was patrick mahomes you
know what i mean like
and so like it was a little easier for
them there i just
i think this is interesting because at
the first sign of trouble
and it's not like a star-studded offense
around 80 dalton
you're going to hear from the fan base
you're going to hear on local radio it's
going to be everywhere put justin fields
in
and i'm with you in that like what's
really interesting about this
is it can be a mechanism to save your
job if you're ryan pace or matt nagy
where
it's if we can at least show ownership
that we got the right quarterback a
and that b we're developing him properly
and we're building momentum going into
2022
it's going to be harder for an owner to
pull the plug on that
than if we just sat him the whole year
nobody knows what he is
great to talk to you as always albert
thank you all right thanks dan
appreciate it that's albert breer senior
nfl reporter
and lead content strategist for the
monday morning quarterback will